on est une gang à faire une battue puis
ben on le trouve pas c'est un drame qui
a marqué tout le Québec un soir de
juillet 2020 deux filles étaient leurs
paires disparaissaient dans les boisés
de Saint-Apollinaire à la suite d'un
mystérieux accident de voiture sur
l'autoroute 20
Laura est remis ont été retrouvés mortes
3 jours plus tard tués par leur père
Martin Carpentier c'est ensuite enlever
la vie deux ans et demi plus tard
l'enquête publique sur les événements
tragiques débute au palais de justice de
Québec pour une durée de 4 semaines une
démarche que réclamait la mère des
fillettes Amélie Lemieux c'est quelque
chose qui me manquait beaucoup beaucoup
pour essayer
d'avancer à travers le deuil de ma vie
Geneviève Guilbaud alors ministre de la
Sécurité publique ordonnait en mars 2022
la tenue de cette enquête publique j'ai
lu comme vous le cri du coeur de la mère
de ses petites filles là qui nous
interpellé et qui a besoin de réponses à
ces questions et je peux la comprendre
parce que je me mets à sa place surtout
depuis que j'ai vu le reportage en quête
personnellement là parce qu'on l'avait
manqué avec le 24 heures qu'on avait
perdu
polisation des unités de recherche de la
SQ
être fait la différence entre la vie et
la mort des carpentiers l'émission
Enquête révélée quelques semaines plus
tôt les ratés de l'opération de
recherche du père et de ses deux filles
les policiers avaient notamment
découvert des traces de pas une piste
qui avait été abandonnée au profit d'une
autre
est-ce qu'on a procédé de façon optimale
pour trouver les victimes Denis boudriat
a été coronaire pendant 25 ans
normalement
l'édition d'entreprise à quel moment les
conséquences taillent une cinquantaine
de témoins seront entendus dans cette
enquête publique présidée par le
coronaire en chef adjoint Luc Malouin
notamment des policiers qui ont
participé aux recherches des enquêteurs
des membres de la famille dont Amélie
Lemieux au jour un des procédures ça
peut rouvrir à des blessures qui
peut-être aller mieux mais qui là vont
pro visiblement là devenir encore plus
douloureuse selon la directrice générale
de de jeunesse cette enquête aidera
certainement la maman à clore un dur
chapitre de sa vie un deuil ou il y a
trop de questions c'est un deuil qui est
beaucoup plus complexe on n'oubliera pas
quelque chose par contre le coronaire
bien qu'il fait un travail
extraordinaire il y a une version qui a
pas c'est celle de la personne qui pue
l'enquête ne lui donnera effectivement
pas la version de celui qui lui a enlevé
ses enfants ici Marie-Pierre Mercier
Radio-Canada Québec